700 c'est le nombre d'animaux que peut
accueillir simultanément le centre de
soins Beauval nature à
Saint-Aignan-sur-Cher mis sur pied en
avril dernier pour venir en aide à la
faune locale en détresse ce centre n'a
pas vocation à transférer les animaux
vers le zoo de Beauval son objectif est
de les soigner afin de pouvoir les
relâcher dans leur milieu naturel des
animaux souvent victimes de l'homme
dérangés ou blessés à cause du trafic
routier ou du braconnage reportage
d'Hélène chapelet
au centre de soins de Beauval le premier
patient de la journée est une jeune
tourterelle attrapée par un chat
l'oiseau présente une plaie importante
sur le flanc et à sans doute une
fracture de l'aile pour en être sûr
Marion et Alizée deux vétérinaires
doivent l'anesthésier l'immobiliser
déclenchée par cette la radio
libre son verdict la fracture est bien
là
et je veux juste regarder s'il y a pas
d'autres fractures
cette petite tourterelle sera donc
opérée prochainement pour qu'on lui pose
des broches en attendant on s'occupe de
nettoyer sa plaie un investissement
important pour un animal plutôt commun
mais cette tourterelle semble avoir de
bonnes chances de guérison ceux qui ont
plus de chance de survie avec moins de
moyens médicaux et de temps on va plutôt
partir sur ces cas-là miser un peu plus
sur ces cas-là et quand par contre on a
des animaux qui sont vraiment très
critiques ou qui nécessitent des fois
des chirurgies et qu'on sait qu'on
n'aura pas le temps de la faire on note
pour une euthanasie parce qu'il y a pas
trop le choix au moment donné
le deuxième patient de la matinée est un
circaète Jean Leblanc un rapace bien
connu de l'équipe puisqu'il est là
depuis l'ouverture du centre
Loir-et-Chérien en avril dernier il
présentait alors deux plaies faites par
des tirs de plomb aujourd'hui il doit
encore être soigné pour des blessures
dus à la captivité et c'est là la
complexité du travail remettre sur pied
des animaux que l'on n'a pas l'habitude
de soigner
ça va du crapaud au
Circet en passant par le renard et
l'hérisson et le petit oisillon c'est
tout en fait
donc oui non c'est vraiment très très
diversifié en versifiant en termes de
d'espèces
c'est vraiment ce qui fait l'intérêt du
métier aussi quand on fait de la
médecine zoologique moi c'est pour ça
que je suis en l'occurrence que je suis
allé m'orienter là-dessus
depuis son ouverture en avril dernier
plus de 600 animaux de la faune sauvage
locale ont déjà été accueillis ici des
mammifères mais aussi des oiseaux amenés
par des particuliers et qu'il faut
nourrir très régulièrement c'est le
travail des soigneurs et des bénévoles
qui se relaient sur place l'objectif à
terme c'est bien de les relâcher dans la
nature car même si la structure est
financée par le zoo de Beauval ces
animaux n'ont rien à faire dans le parc